[Music]  starting an online store is easier than  you think let me show you how to quickly  open one with shopify first go to  shopify.com and start a free trial  next create a beautiful online store  without any design or coding skills  use one of shopify's professional  templates and easily change fonts colors  and images  next add products  just upload a photo and give your  product a name description and set the  price  activate shopify payments and enjoy zero  transaction fees  now let's open your store  just remove the password and ta-dah your  store is live and ready to take orders  are you ready to join the millions of  businesses already using shopify go to  shopify.com and open your online store  today